So, we have another kind of very
interesting piece of the course
right now.  We're going to continue
to talk about genetics, except now
we're going to talk about the
genetics of diploid organisms, which
apart from bacteria, most of the
organisms including us are diploid.
They have more than one copy of each
chromosome, and so we'll go through
a segment on this, and also talk
about mitosis and meiosis, the
central processes of cell division
and the segregation of genetic
material that underlie
life as we know it.
And then, were going to charge into
a session of recombinant DNA, and
some of these technologies, PCR and
various things that you see in the
newspapers all the time.  And then,
I'll finish up with the session on
the immune system, which a few of
you thought was surprising that
bacteria recombine.  I'll tell you
in that system it will feel like
science fiction relative to what
I've told you up to now.
It's an absolutely amazing system.
So, we are going to start today with
genetics of diploid organisms.  So
I'm going to go back to how this was
first understood.  And most of you
have probably heard of Gregor
Mendel, who discovered this, and
surely some fraction of you have run
into an exposure to this topic
before.  But in keeping with what
I'm trying to do in this course,
could you guys watch out there?
I think I'm just going to unplug,
yeah, it's OK.  I think I'm just
going to unplug it for just a minute
here.  You've probably heard of
Mendel.  Some of you have seen these
different squares.  You might have
memorized it from a textbook or
something like that.  I'm going to
try and see if we can go through
this material up another level of
sophistication because, again, and
I'm saying, science didn't just come
down from on high and end up with
facts in a textbook.
What's in a textbook is somebody's
effort to take a current state of
understanding which is based on
experimentation and come up with
models.  And what you're seeing in
the textbooks are the models such as
they were as of the time the
textbook was submitted for
publication.  Sometimes they change
even before the textbooks get out.
But anyway, it's a process.
Mendel was one of the starting
people who started this process,
really a key figure, and a guy with
an amazing intellect.  But before we
start in, I just want to show you a
couple of pictures because these
kind of knocked me over when I saw
them.  I don't know what kind of
image you have of Mendel.  You
probably know he was a monk, and he
did something with peas, and he
figured out this stuff about
genetics.  And most people probably
carry around an image probably
somewhat like this sort of
romanticized drawing.
He was a monk all right, but it was
at an Augustine monastery in Bruno
in Austria that was a very major
intellectual center.  They even
published a scientific journal.
They sent Mendel off to Vienna to go
to university.  While he was there,
he studied physics, math, as well as
botany.  So he had, in many ways, a
background that is very similar to
you guys, very heavy on the
quantitative physical science,
mathematical sort of background.
And then he went on to do some
experiments in biology.  And I think
you maybe can get a sense of this.
You can see a picture of what Mendel
actually looked like.  Here's one
picture of him.  But the one that
really blew me away, I have a
picture of the monks.  Just think of
what ever image you had of the monks
that Mendel was at.
Well there's a picture of them.  To
me, they look nothing so much like a
group of university presidents or
something sitting around for a
portrait.  And he traveled very
widely.  Here he was on his way to
London here.  Here is a picture of
him with a group of people on his
way to, I think he was in Paris on
his way to London.  So this wasn't a
little isolated monk in a garden who
stumbled across stuff.  He was a
rather sophisticated guy going after
some interesting problems.
And this was the garden in which he
did his experiments.  Here's a
picture of it.  So this was a
straightforward experimental setup
for these really amazing things he
did.  So, with that kind of
background, Mendel was interested in
a problem of inheritance.  And
people have been aware that traits
were inherited.
That was the whole principle of
domesticating animals and
domesticating crops, that if you
took parents with certain
characteristics and crossed them
together, the offspring then had the
traits that were associated with the
parents.  And so people were able to
get better domesticated animals or
better domesticated crops.  But up
until then, this mixing was thought
of sort of like blending liquids,
stir together some green and red,
and a little this and that.
And it all stirred together.  And as
you'll see, what one of Mendel's
great insights was, was that it
wasn't like mixing liquids.  And to
study this problem, then, he picked
a system.  It wasn't that he was
just fiddling around with peas.  He
was a pretty sophisticated guy, and
he picked peas as an experimental
organisms for three reasons.
And so, why peas?  Well one, they
were easy to grow, and that's still
a major consideration of any model
system that you want to use and
science today.  It's really tricky
to grow, it's very hard to work
with.  It was easy to pollinate in a
controlled way.
Just the structure of the pea flower
makes it very easy to make sure to
either put the pollen right on the
pistol of that same flower,  which
is a kind of self fertilization, or
to make sure that the pollen goes
from one flower to another, which is
basically cross-pollination.  And
the third thing, and this was a
really important thing, was the
system was worked on before.  And
there were a number of what were
called pure-breeding lines.
If he had just grabbed peas out of
the wild it would be sort of like me
starting to do genetics by crossing
a couple of you guys.  We'd get
offspring, all right, and we'd cross
those offspring, we'd keep getting
things, people that look different
and different, maybe something like
the parents, but what had happened
with peas is people had taken a pea,
and then they continually inbred it
until it finally sort of settled
down.  It always had
white flowers.
It always had wrinkled seeds.  It
always had whatever the particular
trait was.  And so, I think I showed
you this slide earlier.  This shows
two things.  You can see there are
smooth seeds and then wrinkled
seeds.  And it may be a little hard
to tell in this light, but there is
sort of two colors here.  One's kind
of greenish and one's sort of
yellowish.  So there, you see two of
the traits right there.  There were
also flower colors, and height, and
other things that had the
characteristic.
They were pure breeding.  Every time
you took that line and if you self
crossed it and put out its progeny,
you'd see the same characteristic
each time.  So, this was the system
that Mendel started to study this
problem of inheritance.  And how
does blending come together when two
organisms brought pollen?  Or, if it
was other animals like us, it would
be sperm and egg.
But somehow, you did something that
ended up giving you an egg that got
fertilized.  And out of that came
the progeny.  So, what Mendel did,
the term that's used, they say he
carried out a cross.  This is
genetic-speak here now.  So he took
pollen from one plant.
And used it to fertilize another
plant, collected the seeds that came
out of this, and he examined the
progeny.  And I think an interesting
way of thinking about this
is a UROP project.
You'd come into Mendel's lab and
wanted to do a UROP project, it was
pretty easy.  I could probably show
you all the techniques you needed to
know, and this is it.  I'd show
how you pollinate, collect seeds,
and then we'd look at the
characteristics.  So, it's just some
fairly simple manipulations and some
observational stuff.  So, let's
suppose you're doing Mendel's thing
as a UROP project, and let’s just
see where that will take us.
So, what Mendel did to begin with,
he took one of these pure breeding
lines that was smooth or I'll
abbreviated as a capital S.  And he
pollinated it with something that
was wrinkled.  I'll do that as
little S.  And then he collected the
seeds from what's known as the first
generation, starting with
something like this.
And geneticists use the term F1 for
this first generation in a cross
like this, and what he found was
everything, all the seeds, were
smooth.  So, the wrinkled trait had,
if you will, disappeared.
That's your first UROP experiment.
Time to submit to nature, or
science, or something, and write a
little paper like Watson and Crick
that turns the world on its end.
What would you do next?
No gels, no Whitehead Sequencing
Facility.  Anybody got any ideas?
I've showed you all the techniques
that he knew about.  Pardon?  Cross
it again?  What's your thinking?  Do
you think the traits disappear, or
do you think it's hiding?  It might
be hiding, right?
I don't know what he thought, but I
think that's a reasonable to think
about it is he's probably trying to
figure out, did this wrinkled trait
just disappear from the face of the
Earth,  or is it hiding in those
first-generation seeds?  So, let's
put that up here.
So, that's exactly what he did.  So,
he took these seeds, now, that were
the smooth F1.  These are not the
same smooth as the parental up here.
Just to make clear, you guys
understand these are pure breeding.
These are the ones that people have
been breeding for a long time, this
one and this one. In this
case, even though I'm drawing
it in circles, this is a smooth F1,
smooth F1.  And, this time when he
did the experiment he looked at the
second generation, or the F2
generation as a geneticist would
call it.  What he found, he got some
smooth and he got some wrinkled.
So, the wrinkled trait reemerged in
the F2.  So it wasn't really gone.
It was hiding.
OK, time to submit to Nature,
Science or Cell.  Got it?  He didn't
try and publish it at that point.
He did something else.  He had the
same kind of background you guys
have.  Can you think what he might
have done?  He could cross again.
There's something else he did with
this experiment, though.  Well,
you're thinking of new experiments.
He's got a little data processing he
can do here.  What did you say?  I'm
not able to hear, sorry.
Statistics, OK.  I'll simplify it
even slightly before that.  I've got
some of each.  Count them, right,
exactly.  So that's what he did, and
I think the numbers were, if I
remember 5474
and 1850.
So, what should I do now?  Ratio?
Absolutely.  We could count another
million of them, but that probably
would not be terribly productive.
And what he found out is that when
he did that, he found that he got a
ratio that was pretty
close to 3:1.
And, so that was sort of what he
found out from this by doing this
sort of thing over again was a
pattern.  A trait disappeared in the
F1.  The trait reemerged in the F2,
and the two traits had this.
The ratio of the two traits would be
about 3:1.  If you don't think this
is sort of like a UROP project or
something, that's a page out of some
of Mendel's actual notes while he
was doing his crosses.  And what he
did next, then, was to take
some other traits.
Yeah?  Sorry?  Excuse me?  Reemerged
in F2.  So, he took some other
traits, white and purple flowers,
tall, short, I found that there were
at least certain other traits.  It
didn't work for everything he
studied, but some of them he could
see the same pattern.  One of the
traits disappeared.  It reemerged in
the F2, and when he counted them,
he'd find that the trait that
reemerged was at one, and the other
one there were three times as many.
So, he'd seen a pattern.  And all
he's done at this point is to cross
flowers and count the progeny.  So,
at that point Mendel tried to
explain his data.  So, he had to,
now, take the next part of the
scientific process.  And what's kind
of nice about thinking about Mendel,
in this sense, is we are not
overwhelmed by complicated
techniques.
You can see, I think, the scientific
process.  And it's a very bare bones
thing marching along.  So now he's
got some data.  He's quantitated his
stuff.  He's found it reproducible.
It's not only for seeds.  It seems
to be some general feature.  And the
thing about this, I guess, I don't
know what he thought but it seems to
be likely that he could see that
this didn't fit very well with the
blending idea.  Like, you'd pour
together two liquids, and
you'd stir them all up.
Instead, he really made this
monumental leap in thinking that
genetic information must come in
some sort of particular form, come
in particles, or units, or quanta if
you want to think about if it if
you're a physicist.  We know those
units as genes right now.  We grow
up with it right now, but to go from
the idea that genetic information
was kind of like two liquids
blending to the idea it was a little
particle, so it was just about the
same kind of leap as thinking that
energy comes in particles instead of
a continuous sort of thing.
So, that was the kind of insight
that Mendel had.  And so genetic
info comes in particles, units.
I was going to say, we now call
these genes, and if that was what it
was then he started to think about
these traits as particles that had a
different character associated with
each of them.  That would mean there
would be one particle that was a big
S, and that was smooth.  There was
some other particle that was
specified.  The wrinkled character,
that would be called a small s.
So, what was happening in these
crosses, then, he was now mixing
particles instead of liquids.
Again, I don't know how he got to,
how many particles there had to be
of each per organism.  It could have
been anywhere from two upwards.  He
had to have two in order to explain
the sort of stuff he was working
with.  There's no reason he couldn't
have thought of 12 or something.
But I assume you start with the very
simplest thing, number that you can
think of, and see if you can make
this work.  So, what he
hypothesized, then, was that each
organism had two copies of each of
these particles.  So, two copies of
each particle, so this would mean
that there were two types
of particles.
So, there would be the S and the
smooth.  So, he can get three types
of things.  He could get one that
was both big S or smooth.  Or you
could have the ones that were the
two little S's.  And these
would be wrinkled.
Or, if you had the other
combination, what he figured out,
what fit with this model is these
would have to be smooth.  That would
have to mean that one of them is
dominant over the other when you put
them in combination.  So, in this
thing, the big S would be
said to be dominant.
And the little s Would be said to be
recessive.  There's another little
term here that I'm going to
introduce because it'll help us talk
about this stuff over the next few
days, terms geneticists use all the
time.  Because these both have two
of the same, they're said to be
homozygous, do the same.  And this
one, with one of each, is said to be
heterozygous.
OK, so there is, I think, sort of
the setup for Mendel's model.  He
had to contend with one other issue,
though, and that was if every
organism has two, and two parents
get together and each donate
something, unless you did something,
the offspring would have four.  When
those offspring got together, the
next one would have twice
as many, and so on.
So, from probably, I don't know
whether it was just from first
principles, but I would imagine he
figured out that if organisms had
sex with pollen and whatever, or egg
and sperm, that something had to be
done to get around this problem of
an ever increasing number of
particles.  So, he envisioned that
when there were specialized cells
for sex, and that they have the
number so that the sex cells would
have half the number of particles so
that when each parent donated one,
you'd be back up to two.
It's pretty simple, straightforward
thinking once you've gotten the idea
that these things are coming in a
particular form.  So, with this,
could he now explain his results?
Let's do it over here.  So, what
happened in the first cross?  He had
a smooth, pure breeding line crossed
with, so the sex cells from this,
each one would have been a big S,
and the sex cells from each one of
this would have been a little s.
And as you recall, what he got was
all smooth, right?  Remember?
So, if we try and figure out what's
happening here, a way of
representing this would be to think
what happens if all of the
combinations that you could get, so
if we paired them in all possible
ways, then every combination would
be identical from that first cross,
one from one parent,
one from the other.
And, if one was dominant over the
other, it's going to look like this.
This is really the word I
introduced you to.  That's the
genotype.  That's what's going on
down at the genetic level.  What
you're seeing up here is the
observable characteristics
of the organism.
That would be the phenotype.  So,
then what would happen then with
this if he crossed the F1's?  Well,
as you recall, they were smooth, but
he was now seeing them as being like
this.  So that means that the sex
cells that are generated from this,
each one will generate one big S,
and one little s.
And then, if you put them together
to see how this would work out,
well, this one's two big S's.  This
is a big S and a little s, a big S
and a little s, and two little s's.
So, what he's got over here is SS,
Ss, and ss in a ratio of 1:2:1.
But when you look at the phenotype,
what would we expect?  Well, this
would be smooth, big S and little s.
That's smooth.  Big S, little s,
smooth again, and two little s's,
that's wrinkled.
There's his ratio of 3:1.  Has he
proved anything?  It works.
Beautiful.  The model must be right?
What do you think?  Are you ready
to publish?  Why is that?  Why did
the model work?
Has the model predicted anything
yet?  No, it works because it
describes the data.  To some extent,
it's kind of like hitting a curve.
You said it, but you don't really
know yet.  Of course it's going to
work, because if you got different
data it would've had a different
model.  So, you're putting your
finger on a really important point,
and that is that you can do an
experiment.  You can get data.  It
doesn't have to involve DNA
sequencing or fancy techniques.
You're getting data out of
a biological system.
You've come up with a hypothesis
that explains it.  But of course
it's going to explain it because you
wouldn't publish a model that didn't
explain your own data.  But what he
hasn't done is tested it.  Will his
model predict the outcome of
something that he hasn't already
done?  So, the suggestion was that
he should carry out another cross.
And that's what Mendel
then did again.
This is what he had to work with.
He could cross, and he could count,
and he could do some calculating and
some thinking.  But, those were the
techniques.  I really like thinking
about this, because you can sort of
put yourself in his shoes.  So, what
would you guys like to cross?  We
haven't got much, right?  One, he
did.  One cross he did, the F1 with
the homozygous dominant parent, the
pure breeding lines.
So, he's got this smooth, that's a
big S and a little s, and he's
crossing it with something, two big
S's.  So, the sex cells that you'll
get out of this, so if you set this
one up and see what happens,
there's the two.
You will get to big S's, big S,
little S, the big S, little S.  This
is sort of uninformative.  If you
want to look at your notes
afterwards, and have this be
consistent, let me just
flip this slightly.
I put the two big S's up here, and
this is our F1 down here.  That way
I'll be following the same pattern
as I did before.  OK, so there we
are.  In any case, they're all
smooth, but that's not particularly
helpful.  He's seen that result
before.  It hasn't really proven
out.  Given the sort of unexpected
result that's predicted by his
model.  But he tried another one
that's very, very similar.
And in this case, he crossed the F1
with the homozygous recessive
parent.  This is a really important
process in genetics.
And the reason, because it's so
important, it's given a special term
that's called a test cross.  Let's
see what happens with this one,
because this one's more interesting.
So, we take the F1.  So, this is
the F1.  He's now crossing it with
this homozygous recessive, so a
parent that's got two particles that
are little s. And so,
will the sex cells look like this:
a big S little s as before, two
little S's here?  So, if we set up
this, as we've done, there are the
sex cells from this F1.  Here are
the sex cells from the homozygous,
recessive parent.  Up here, we get a
big S and a little s for
each of those.
But here, we get two little s's.
So, if we look at the phenotype, if
you're out on the field or out in
the garden sitting in the kitchen,
after you brought your seeds in or
wherever he was working, what would
you predict you'd see in a cross
like this?  These would be both
smooth, but these would
both be wrinkled.
So, here at the genotypic level,
we've got a ratio, now, of 1:1.  And
here as well, there's now a ratio of
1:1.  So, there you have a result
that you haven't seen before.  And,
if you do that cross and get that
result, again, it doesn't prove your
model.  Scientific proof
is never a QED.
Somebody can always come up with an
experiment tomorrow that disproves
it.  It tends to work more.  You
just keep shoveling on evidence, and
finally someone says, enough,
enough, I believe you.  So, this was
at least a test of the model, and
the model survived this task.  Now,
he did one other experiment.  Of the
things that we've got on our plate
right now, is there anything else we
might do you can think of?
He did another cross.  Pardon?  Two
of the heterogeneous ones? We did
the F1's against each other.  That's
where we got the 3:1.  We've already
crossed the F1's, but I like your
idea.  What if we took the F2's?
In this case, it's going to be
pretty complicated because they've
got this 2:1:1, but one of the
things you can do with peas is you
can self fertilize them as well as
cross them with their neighbors
because they've got the ability to
make the eggs.  It'll become the
seeds, and they have the pollen,
which would be equivalent to the
sperm.  So it got both.
So, as long as there's some plants
that you can self fertilize and some
you can't, one of the really nice
things about peas, they have the
property that you can self fertilize
them.  So, another kind of
experiment that Mendel did, then,
was to self fertilize another test
of the model, self fertilize the
F2's.  Well, the model predicts, if
we look back over there, that what
you'll have there is a mix of things
in a ratio of 1:2:1.
So, if you were to take seeds from
that F2, and then cross them with
themselves, you could figure out all
the different outcomes, and then sum
them up.  You'd have a prediction
for what this model
would suggest.
All right, so let me just take you
through the pieces.  Let's think
about a quarter of them, according
to the model, a quarter are that.
So, if we self cross those, what we
should get is all wrinkled because
the only thing we're dealing with is
the wrinkled trait.  So, that would
be a quarter of the F2 seeds would
be expected to give that outcome.
So, three quarters of them are
smooth, but it's tricky because
there's two types of them in there,
right?  So, of these, one third are
this, and two thirds have that.
So, what would happen if we thought
about each of those individually,
and thought about the outcome?
Well, if we take the SS type, and
we've self crossed them, what we're
going to get is all smooth because
all we've got in the cross are the
traits for the smooth
characteristic.  And, if we take
these guys and we've self-crossed
them, we've already done that.
We know what we will get is we will
get smooth to wrinkled in a ratio of
3:1.  So, again, you could now sit
down with that and figure out in
total what you would predict in
terms of smooth and wrinkled if you
self crossed the F2, and if
the model is correct.
So, that was basically your first
UROP project, or the end of the
first term, or the first year, or
something like that.  And he did
publish those results that were
published in 1866, which was the
same year as those, about the same
time as those results that Pasteur
was publishing that I told
you about earlier on.
So, it was a very impressive in
retrospect, a truly major
intellectual leap.  But, it had
almost no impact at all on the
world.  And there's a theme here
that it sort of tried to
hit up several times.
And we saw it, to some extent, with
the early work on DNA, that someone
can get evidence for an idea.  But
if the scientific community is ready
to accept it, it can take quite
awhile before that idea becomes
credible even if it's correct.  The
data was there.  The DNA was genetic
material quite a bit before the
general scientists thought it was,
and it just seemed like it was too
simple a molecule, too boring a
molecule to be possibly able
to encode anything.
And the same sort of thing happened
here.  It was some geneticists
picked up on this but not
until about 1900.